path space manipulation this is again
from the kid guys this is a wonderful
tool now what happens if the artist
would create a scene that he really
likes but there are some artifacts or
some small effects that he would like to
get rid of what do you have to do well
obviously you have to change the
physical parameters because this is what
physical reality would look like but
still you could say that if you take a
look at the left image you don't really
like the reflections on the wall behind
or you don't like the incoming direction
of the sunlight or maybe you don't like
the reflection of the car in the mirror
so for instance for the mirror what if
we could pretend that the normal of the
mirror wasn't what it is but it would
have been something different and this
is exactly what this work gives you and
on the right you can see a side-by-side
comparison of the original image and the
manipulated scene it looks much better
and you don't have to change a single
thing in your scene you just manipulate
and you just bend the some of the light
paths there are in the scene
imagine that you don't like the caustics
on the bunny and you can just basically
grab and pull the thing onto the face of
the bunny it is really really amazing
this work maybe one of the reasons one
of many if I may add for Pixar to change
from their race renderer that has a long
history of more than 25 years of movies
and wonderful works and now they have
changed to path tracing they use global
illumination in their newest movies and
imagine how powerful this tool can be in
the hands of a professional artist let
alone a team of professional artists we
have some amazing times ahead in global
illumination research residue ratio
tracking this is a Disney paper this is
basically about how to render
heterogeneous participating media what
does it mean
heterogeneous means that either the
density or the scattering or absorption
properties of the medium are changing in
space they are not uniform this
technique helps you to render this kind
of like transport
much more quickly than previous methods
it builds on Woodcock tracking it
improves Woodcock tracking but it is
basically the industry standard way of
rendering heterogeneous materials and
what it does essentially is a
mathematically really appealing way of
probabilistically treating the scene as
if it was homogeneous instead so trying
to reduce the problem to a simpler
problem that we can solve easily and
doing some probabilistic tricks over
this classification and this gives you
an unbiased estimator for the
heterogeneous participating medium and
this piece of work is an improvement
even over debt this was done by young
Novak and colleagues at Disney in this
work by Alexander Wilkie who by the way
used to be a PhD student here at our
University and he graduated here now he
moved to the Czech Republic and he's
doing wonderful work we discussed
earlier that if you would like to do
fully spectral rendering then you take a
random sample in the spectrum of visible
wavelengths and he came up with a trick
that if you do this in a way that is
just a bit smarter than what we do
naively then you can get results like
this using the same number of samples
you can see that the noise is much more
representative to the actual image that
were rendering let's take a look at
another example how about this this is
the naive spectral rendering and his
technique called the hero wavelength
spectrum sampling amazing piece of work
you should definitely definitely check
it out I promise to you that we would
start out with algorithms from 1986 up
to until last week so this literally
appeared last week this is the gradient
domain path tracing algorithm but I will
also use a figure from the gradient
domain metropolis paper for better
understand ability so the key idea is
that we are not seeking the light
anymore we are seeking changes now what
does it mean take a look at the image on
the upper left it says that we're
basically interested in this small
region that is a hard shadow boundary
and below it the image says that let's
say that this whatever function that
will compute
is zero in the shadow boundary and one
outside you can intuitively imagine that
this means that yes we have no radiance
in the faroe boundary and we have a
really bright region outside what would
the regular metropolis sampler do well
it is a Markov chain that in its
stationary distribution would like to do
optimal important sampling what does it
mean it means that the brighter reagent
would be sampled more so you can see the
red dots in there we would sample this
region that is one all the time we would
never put any sample in the zero what if
we are not seeking for the light we are
seeking for changes so imagine that we
are interested in putting samples at the
shadow boundary because we know that
there is some change happening in there
but the right and from the left to it
there's absolutely no change so if I get
enough information only of the shadow
boundary then I can reconstruct the
whole image with a technique that is
called parcel image reconstruction
this means intuitively something like
reconstructing a function from its
gradients you can imagine it in 1d as
something like you have a 1d function
you are interested in the function but
the only thing you have is how the
function changes you have derivatives
and from these derivatives you would
like to reconstruct the function this is
exactly what the algorithm does and it's
an amazing idea love it you can see that
it significantly outperforms path
tracing with a much lesser number of
samples now let's note that because of
the pass or reconstruction step the 5k
SPP is compared to the 2k SBP this is
probably because it is more expensive to
draw samples with this gradient domain
path tracing but you can see that this
smart algorithm is really worth the
additional time
another great paper from last week from
our friends at Disney what if we would
have a scene where we build a castle out
of sand
and what if we are crazy enough that we
would like to render every small grain
of sand that is in the castle that would
mean billions upon billions of objects
that's a lot of intersections that's a
lot of problems even if you have some
kind of spatial acceleration structure
so this would take forever and a day and
they came up with a really cool solution
that can give you these beautiful
beautiful results at least an order of
magnitude faster I also promise to you
that I would refer you to
implementations of many of the discussed
algorithms so this is a huge list some
of them are implemented only on the CPU
some of them have also GPU
implementations so take a look and play
with them it's lots of fun and if you're
watching this lecture on the internet
and don't worry about the links in the
video description box I provide a link
to these slides and you can just click
away at them and there are some must-see
videos some awesome slow-motion fracture
tests with SOG well smashing virtual
objects is a lot of fun slow motion
videos are a lot of fun so this
absolutely has to be a crazy good video
and it really is and the remarkable
thing about this is that the whole thing
took 25 seconds to render per HD frame
I've also uploaded a bonus unit on how
to use together blender and Lux render
basically this means that you model
something in blender and you would like
to export this scene and render it in
Lux render this is going to be useful in
the next assignment